you guys gotta hit me with uh
a badass old war story man i'm gonna say
one thing
i can't what which one can we tell
maybe a lot of it was about sex and girl
okay hey
eddie murphy harlem nights premiere
[Music]
another episode of hot boxing with mike
tyson and
evan britton and we have such a special
guest here today today
the dear friend of mine is also a
person's friend i'll be sure
it's a sensation new r b singer he's the
man he i think he just got off tour
he's my brother and everybody he's here
for you
i'll talk to the people welcome yes sir
yes welcome brother good to see you
thank you for the invitation uh this is
this is truly amazing we've had such an
amazing
amazing journey over the years i agree
man and
it's just it's good it's good to see
where we are today
and uh you know we are thriving and we
are blessed
and and continue here come on you know
what it is thank god you know that
mountain we've climbed
that's amazing my michael and i have had
these parallel universes you know
whether
whether we see each other all the time
or maybe don't you know from traveling
and i'm on tour and he's taking care of
his business and stuff but
what the brotherhood remains always so
i'm gonna tell you the first time i met
you must have been 85 80 but i think
we're at 85 86
you don't remember you was in upstate
new york albany new york you don't
remember this
and you were with who are you with come
on what was his name again
um now were you in training camp
in the mountains at night time you had a
show and then you came to this bar
everybody was that it was a black bar um
was it was it dion sanders no he was the
guy he was with
he used to hang out with andre all the
time who's his name
uh mookie no he was on that rookie the
big guy this other guy
i forgot his name he's always saying he
had a baby with a cameron
um white stuff what's his name sugar
dice sugar dice yeah i got a baby
sugar diced sugar big shout out to sugar
you know what that brings me to because
i remember uh the first
tour uh when i first got signed to
warner brothers and
we were all on the airplane together and
then for some reason years later like i
see
it's still like online that that karen
white and i are dating
who yeah you yeah that's something but i
don't know where they got the story from
like
i haven't seen karen you know big shout
out to cameron the love white what
an amazing talent but that was our first
tour
um when we i went from the bedroom in
mount vernon
to being in japan in front of 10 000
japanese citizens
that basically didn't speak english but
they knew the the every
lyric to the song and it was the most
fascinating experience for me
the first time out in the road when i
was just rehearsing to
audition in my bedroom it was crazy and
then almost
i'm i'm thousands of miles away and
and these amazing japanese citizens are
singing along whoo
doing all the stuff i'm like wow i said
is this what this is supposed to be like
so so you talk about just an epiphany
and just dreaming it to fruition that's
that's kind of my you know been my thing
too lately mike which has been
you know just everything is about the
power of positive thinking oh absolutely
absolutely i've even started i've
started a new campaign called
i am new jacksexy.com
and and it's not about me it's just
about every day that you are gifted
enough to wake up in the morning
look in your mirror those words are the
most two important important words in
the world
i am now what do you put behind that is
what you are
yes sir i'm a no good rotten [ __ ] [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
that's what you are i am god i am a
beautiful person
i am loving i am caring i am gratitude
that's what you are
yes sir i am that's what you are yeah
that's it
and that's what and that's what i wanted
to start you know very specifically
i've been through and michael you've
known me for so many years in terms of
in terms of the journey and having uh
i want to cut that off
sometimes mike's phone goes off i
couldn't because i'll constantly yeah
wait let's see thanks nick no i can't do
that who is it
we can't do that um
so i've so i've embarked upon this
journey of um you know kind of health
and wellness
i mean mike you've you've known me since
you know i was 17 years old
um and i was i was i weighed about 160
back then
and then you know and then i kind of you
know went through this journey this
musical journey all over and
and then i ran from that hole people
asked me you know how did you gain so
much weight i got to like 305. wow
so within the i'll fast forward so
within the last year or so
i made a decision to to be in charge of
my star player
and that's supposed to be me and and not
and not deal with the diabetes type 2
and just try to be healthy you know and
obviously you know where we live in
vegas it's the devil's
the devil's workshop you know workshop
you know and you got to just
you just got to you know you got to do
what you do and
you know the bottom line is i just made
a decision to say you know what let me
uh
evolve you know and and it's a mind body
and spirit thing so let me evolve so
long story short over the last year i've
lost
100 pounds wow i threw up a small child
in their friend
if you don't evolve you're no longer
allowed to exist so you have to evolve
yes sir yeah and i did it and i did it
in you know
different ways you know first i started
which we were just talking about earlier
you know
cut out the bread rice pasta sugar i did
all that because sugar is worse than
heroin oh it's
worth addicting so you have to wean your
body off of all the other stuff first
and then i wound up doing surgery and
everybody asked me how did you lose all
this weight
you know i i wanted doing a bariatric
surgery and uh
and it was the best thing for me very
specific because you know my grandson my
five-year-old grandson i told him five
years old
i tell you what he said to me it was
this was kind of the last straw
his last birthday uh he walks over to me
and this is now mind you this is august
so he
walks over and he taps me on the belly
says pop-pops uh
maybe you could play santa claus for my
next birthday i was like
got it got it take over
wow that's amazing man i was three
i was probably 3 30. okay when i was in
the league
wow yeah so over the last four years i
dropped the weight pretty quick i've
lost about
80 pounds i'm 255 now that's fantastic
and how tall are you as well six six
seconds
that you yeah you kind of up to you
gravity
but man i know how that feels man that
you know
we we carry a lot of weight because we
try to pack on the armor
you know to protect ourselves from all
the [ __ ] we've been through or we're
running from something right exactly
and sometimes we're just not happy with
ourselves you know and then you have to
you have to read
mike you said something so incredible
early just about about it finding that
that true happiness and you know you
were talking about the toad
and and stuff like that that people may
not be familiar with but it's the most
amazing thing when you can finally say
to yourself
or like one of the greatest things that
i saw mike do over the past few years is
his one-man show
and what it said to me is as michael's
evolving
from the standpoint of when you can
laugh at yourself
it takes you to another level when you
can people got to stop taking themselves
so seriously you know it's like okay
you're fantastic you're great
but you know i'm small i'm minuscule as
it relates to whatever
the rest of the universe and what what
god is all about you know
it's like you you have to when you start
when you start when you put yourself in
your place
yeah you know that's that's when you you
can really start to grow and evolve and
i'm just so proud of my brother cena
absolutely man thank you
it's just that um after i mean being
involved with the toad um you just you
start to wonder about things like what's
really happening after this life is over
after this physical body is gone
yeah this don't stop functioning what we
what we're experiencing now don't start
functioning
i think we go to another dimension or
something but i don't believe it died i
believe the body dies
right there's energy in the body doesn't
die mike don't you feel it
though in some ways maybe not to the
extent but
in many ways you were on that path like
al is saying
you know before you came to the toad
you know your undisputed was
that was a toad experience for you
because that was a shedding of skin
that was uh coming into the light that
was uh that was fascinating to watch
michael get emotional and and very
specifically when he was asked that one
question
you could tell the sincerity yeah and
the genuine nature of what he was
speaking about and it was
you know it was like a release and i
loved it because imagine
i imagine imagine this man spends his
entire life
entertaining planet earth yeah okay you
know i mean who who doesn't
you know who doesn't love to see the
knockouts mike tyson knockouts and watch
all the footage and all you know and
and watch mike and ali together with ray
you know like i just watched
the clip from arsenio the other day and
it was just it's just amazing you know
and just how he humbles himself yes you
know
yes absolutely the bottom line is at the
end of the day we are still here it is
30 35 years later mike and and and we
are taking it to another level
to a new gravity a new frequency um
daily and and we're just like computers
my thing is this update your software
um yeah windows 92 works you know it
might be cool but
it's not going to do much for you right
now yeah so update your software as
you know what are you thinking like even
with you what do you think all these
people since
since the age since i since your life
you know you're young since our life
and the people you know they're not
hitting them all these guys they were
smarter than us they had more money they
had better family they had better
educations
and i thought why didn't this you know
these guys probably killed themselves i
died of
overdose well i was going to say uh that
thank you mike that reminds me of this
other thing i wanted to say about what
you were saying
mike being this beacon of light for that
to be able to
laugh at yourself and to forgive
yourself
and release yourself because so many
people take themselves
themselves so seriously that they're
killing themselves
and others over it and they're doing a
great job of fronting in terms of you
know
whatever the perception that they wish
to give out
and and and you know sometimes it's just
the devil
yeah that's all it is
yeah well there's this interesting uh
i've been diving
it's awesome to we we it seems that we
just gravitate
people come in here who are on this path
you know
al and it's so i mean i could listen to
your voice all day dude
amazing amazing radio station i know
of course it's it's you know the soul
just
flows out of it man thank you and it's
it's beautiful
um but
you know that just being on the
spiritual path and
um i forgot what i was going to say
you know it is a journey but yeah even
being on a spiritual path and having a
focus
journey and having an idea that's what i
tell most people just in terms of uh
you know whatever you do have a plan you
don't have to stick to the plan
because guess what the mountain falls
down it's raining the weather you've got
to turn up another road
there's all type of things to divert you
from from the goal
but at least you have a plan you have an
objective and i think that's probably
the best thing you know as it relates to
you know whatever you're you're looking
to accomplish yeah i mean i always say i
do my little broadcast you know daily
and i say listen
dream it to fruition see yourself in
that space you know if you
if you if you need to everything from
something superficial like if you want a
new car
you know see picture yourself in the car
go to the dealer go sit in the car you
know do whatever
or or let's say you're trying to beat
cancer or let's say you have a disease
or something you have to see yourself
see yourself in that position and i
think that gives you the best
percentage and opportunity to win moving
forward or getting to your particular
goal
do you guys feel like since you were
little kids you felt you had a mission
that's weird you said it because i was
thinking yesterday i said well i'm
thinking about when i was younger
i said why did why did it happen i felt
like i was special in a way i felt like
i wasn't gonna die i felt like
something was gonna happen you know i
lived in such a dire straight situation
yeah you know but then you wind up
feeling like an alien like there's just
something
different there's something you know
it's not about being more special than
anyone else yeah no
there's something different something
very different about your frequency yeah
i'm different than the rest of my
friends yeah it's different than them
yeah but you're scared to leave the
neighborhood they scared me
and i i always go in other neighborhoods
i go walk all across town all over the
place
you know i mean i get confronted by
other gangs members and stuff
sometimes they may beat me up they want
to take my money and sometimes they say
you're cool
shorty but i'm always confronting myself
with different obstacles in my life
i think then that you know what's
amazing i think that's the same synergy
that you and i have had
because i remember at times like michael
and i would be
at mr chow on 57th street in new york
and we would have dinner you know we
have some
some ladies with us hanging out so and
so forth and then we look at each other
and go
yo let's go to paris over there
but it was in terms of we would just
it's called having an open mind and and
being accepted you know accepting
everyone for who they are
there's no no closed minded anything and
then we weren't afraid to travel we
would just get on a plane go to germany
go to
go to paris young kids
and people we thought listen that's so
dope young we are at least from our
experience so young black kids we didn't
know black kids
from 50 to 20s or the 70s that did they
just picked up money unless there was
some
drug dealers but we didn't know anybody
they weren't going with no concert or no
um supervisionist two but i could just
get up and we go to another country
and it's party but what did you always
do when you went to
terms
they treat us different over there they
treat us over there
they wouldn't ever think about arresting
us over there they arrest us over here
in a minute holy [ __ ]
so oh man i i remember though it was
funny because
as every time michael and i see each
other we'll we start we'll reminisce
about like well remember
remember we were you know in this
country remember we were at this fight
and something because i made it i made
it a point to uh i think
our friendship developed over you know
over time from the standpoint
of knowing that he had a friend that
number one will tell him the truth
i'm not a yes guy and i'm the guy who
does who doesn't
and someone who didn't need to want
anything from him but but his success
that was that was my requirement i want
you to try
i think i saw him on instagram somewhere
he'll reach out sugar dice if
you if you're here i think you're dead
man
please i think he's alive and well he's
alive and well
uh you guys gotta hit me with uh
a badass old war story man i'm gonna say
one thing oh i can't
what which ones can we tell maybe
a lot
[Music]
eddie murphy's harlem nights premiere
i'm dressed as a gangster i'm looking
beautiful versace dress pinstripe
wool gangster looking suit from like the
mike's wardrobe
and i got the the turban the hat the
brim and the whole thing and so i'm
hanging out
and i'm hitting on these two asian girls
who look beautiful i'm hitting on them
right but they're not talking to me
and no and stuff and so i'm pissed off
and i leave
so the premier the the show is over
right the movie's over i come out
i see him he got the two same girl hey
you like to hang out with us and i said
yes i got a hotel room right there and
he had to go in the hotel
and he said the same girl they wouldn't
talk to me he said hey i got somebody he
didn't even know that
i was trying to talk to you the movie's
over i see him and say hey man you wanna
hang out with us
yeah i got a hotel right over there man
come on my hotel room
that's like what you were saying you
guys are in like first
parallel universes always man
when what's that when did that happen
you're talking to these two girls and
they're not giving you any rhythm
then you watch the movie you call them
when you see your friend well hey you
want to hang out with us
yeah yeah i remember let me see
one of the stories i remember there was
a place called was it roxbury
roxbury was la and la the l.a club and
you know at any given point it would be
you know myself
michael um
eddie eddie murphy yeah all
you know just all all the big actors and
stuff and we just
we would have such a good time but it
was like it was like a a very small knit
community that we all kind of associate
because like even
you remember when i did my my second
album when i did private times and the
whole night i actually
recorded the entire album i was working
with i think rick james and eddie murphy
at the time
so i recorded at bubble hill at eddie's
and he had the most beautiful yeah
beautiful mansion there the studio and
the bowling alley like you like you had
the bowling alley yeah he's been pretty
awesome yeah
and uh i learned a lot from eddie you
know the kid being around him and
looking at his house and this stuff
yeah and he was like and he was the blue
he was like the blueprint of fly
yeah he was the blueprint of class and
fly and he made it
because he was out in the early 80s we
came out in the middle 80s close to the
end of 80s
but he came out in the early 80s so he
was before us and he see him with the
rose voices the manchester united so he
was trying to hang around him
yeah we were hanging with him we fell
this is what we're going to do we get
some money like we were famous
but we didn't get the check yet you know
we were with all the famous people and
the rich people but we didn't get to
check once we got the check we knew what
we were gonna
do we were prepared we knew what to do
okay this is what we're gonna do when we
get that check
wow oh i've been to the library's
apartment man it was like bigger than
like the hole along with the whole block
it goes on it goes all the way around
the whole central park
listen man i said this is what i'm gonna
do when i get my money that's what
you're gonna do and i get to check
this these guys prepare you for when you
get the check that's what happened when
you're young you're up and coming
everybody sees your special
you try hanging around you start hanging
around these guys and you know they seem
like normal guys but if you know their
fame but they hang out
and then you know that especially when
you go to their house
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i remember going to the normal
[ __ ] right here to be hanging
out with us yeah it's like you you can
get exercise just walking around the
house you know
20 acres you know but but i remember
probably one of the most fascinating uh
one of the most fascinating visits that
i had i think it was maybe it was
it was christmas time or something and i
remember going to
mike douglas and catherine zeta-jones
place in new york
and it was the entire top floor of like
one of the new york city buildings
and you look out and you see central
park you know what have you and i was
you know and then and then we all it was
i think it was myself and
um you know we all got in the piano
catherine zeta jones can sing
like she can sing a face off yeah she
goes in so let's just imagine
everybody's having a good time and it
was just like one community of just
people just having a ball and just
having fun and enjoying themselves
and and i miss that sometimes too you
know
man is it different now well for me
let me tell you the blessing the
blessing for me as it relates
to now i'm a bit of a like don't let the
love songs fill you i'm
a bit of a nerd you know so i'm into
google analytics and data and
things of that nature and understanding
that very specifically as it relates to
r b
and new jack swing and that that era of
music that late 80s you know 90s
the digital footprint for this
particular genre of music is so
significant
all around the globe right now and i'm
elated that my phone's ringing
it's like i'm old black justin bieber or
something like it's crazy it's like 1988
everywhere i go and it's just a
testament to to
knowing that and this is something i i
talk about when i you know one of these
speeches and stuff i say listen there's
a generation of women
who are starving to be told i love you
again so they gravitate towards our
music
bobby brown new edition i'll be sure
keith sweat
tony in vogue swv like this there's this
pocket of music that's
just that feel good fun that i remember
wearing
it's not like i love you and sounding
like a [ __ ] yeah i mean i love you so
dearly my love and your sound like it's
like a manly i love you with all my
heart sincerely
and then with some cool forgive me okay
forgive me i love you sincerely forgive
me yeah
and you know what's funny so my my first
tour so you know i remember i think i
just went
i just went to see you in atlantic city
you you won one of your 100 belts
and and then we it was myself and
kimberly i remember that day
yeah that was a good night we had a
wonderful time
really great god rest her soul um
yeah she loved you too man you just you
always such a gentleman
and i remember after i had gone on tour
and i remember we got to madison square
garden and in fact i just saw
um the amazing job that uh that jesse
collins uh
uh um uh entertainment did you know uh
did with the new addition stories and
the bobby brown story yeah
amazing story so i remember that they
showed you on the show yeah
and i remember we i think we sold out
madison square garden four nights in a
row now imagine
i'm this kid from mount vernon from up
the street also right outside of the
bronx is four square miles
and i would be in my room doing little
dance steps trying to copy
you know new addition and watch them
perform and you know and i really want
to do that
you know i want to i want to be on the
so you know the soul train awards i want
to be on the you know
the grammys i want to be and i would
just i would i would speak it into
fruition you know
and i remember so we got we finally hit
the new york
uh the new york circuit of the tour
madison square garden
that particular night i think my album
just went platinum
and so i decided to
do a surprise for my dear friend and we
got him a big platinum
and i brought michael on i remember this
i brought michael on stage
right now mind you this place was about
22
20 000 22 000. so we walk out
mike walks out and you could hear
the rumble all the way in new jersey
the people went nuts now you thought you
would you would think that it was alve's
show bobby run a new edition on the
stage all at once no when mike came out
on the stage they lost their
mind and it was it was the greatest
thing to see and he was just so humble
you know michael has that walk he's just
like i'm just chilling
and uh and then and so i so i found the
photo
i finally that's the one i just tell you
i just found the photo of me and mike
holding the thing
and i'm all but i'm all like now now i
lost the weight again i was gonna say
before
i'm almost getting my mike used to see
him and of course you know mike is just
like
it was crazy so awesome but it was just
fun times like that just
just remembering you know just back in
in the youth and
and then we'd leave from there and then
i go to this training camp
youth is the [ __ ] man you [ __ ]
man you're so lucky yeah
wow wow crazy listen well you got to
bring mike on stage again
yeah oh that was dope that was
so there was so much fun in fact um you
know official alby shores you know my
instagram
and so i have a clip on there so if you
get a chance to check it out there's a
clip
uh of of the launch of obviously
this amazing organization obviously you
know tyson ranch and
the kind festival it was was it uh
miguel
yeah and asap and and what a turnout i
mean it was
thousands and thousands of young people
just filling the stands and
so i took some footage and we cut it
together and it looked crazy
it looks incredible in fact i make sure
i afford it so you have it
but it was uh but but i'm looking
forward to it i mean you guys have some
really amazing
amazing things in the works don't want
to put some dwink on it look at twink
y'all
yeah we got cbd infused water
and we've got cbd sodas and thc
sodas che and the cbd and what you know
and
i'm glad we brought that up because what
people don't realize very specifically
traditionalists
um and in the modern era this is so
significant for health and wellness and
healing and things of that nature people
who are dealing with whether sickle cell
anemia or
or oh yeah you know just all type of
ailments
this is this is all about healing now
yeah it is but you know al
listen and and i want to sell my product
it'll take um i think another generation
for the kids to understand they have to
um
they got the first stop becoming
addicted by the poison that we've been
taking we're addicted to it so it's
gonna be hard to give it up
all of the processed foods and all the
sugar and all this it's hard to give it
up
yeah that's gonna be easy sugar they're
not gonna give up without a fight
trust me sugar they're not giving up
without a fight i don't know man
so you know you know it's gonna be
processed you know some people
we're the only species that notice kill
us and we still take it
only species that do stuff like that so
weird
yeah so well you know that makes a lot
of sense it really does
but yeah but i'm but i'm happy like this
is what's great you like i said you've
spent your entire existence
entertaining planet earth in terms of
you know putting your body through this
i mean it's almost impossible even just
to think of it like
that's why anybody who who knows that
you know we know each other they'll say
the first thing that i tell him i said
you couldn't walk a millisecond in his
shoes
that's why you know like that's why you
can't say nothing to me about mike texas
i'm just going to tell you now you
cannot walk a second in his shoes
with this man he sacrificed his body his
whole life you know entertaining the
entire planet
and now you've you've taken part two
because we don't call it a comeback we
just called it now you're updated you're
updating your software yeah no doubt
about it it's part two
and now what you've done is now you're
giving back on the health and wellness
side of things because you know you also
have the stuff you know the
the pain management stuff and and and so
imagine who's the who's the best
representative between you and shaquille
the two best people on the planet to to
deal with pain management because
imagine
shaquille was like the mike tyson of the
nba because imagine having to be
the most dominant you're the most
dominant of all time
shaquille the most dominant player you
know just you know no respect to any
other players
a good comparison right but it's but but
meaning that you in there banging like
you in there
going in and people and they trying to
hurt you yeah you know yeah
it's like you got you going to work and
somebody's trying to hurt you absolutely
you're going up against new fresh meat
all the time yeah
you know guys who want to prove
themselves exactly
against the great mike tyson right and
so i have a question for you mike so
what do you think your greatest
challenge challenge was as as
being a prize fighter being a world
renowned prize fighter what was your
greatest challenge
was it the training was it the actual
fight or was it you know like what
what would you think just just off the
top
with me it was me it was my
my demons my psychology not saying why
is it me why do i have this and these
guys don't what makes me different than
these guys
me doubting myself and questioning
myself
that's why me and not them he's smarter
than me more judging had a better family
he you know why not why haven't i
managed to question myself all the time
but in front of the world i told him
about this i'm the best fighter god
created this nobody could beat me
but you know i never could understand
that you know why is that why am i
getting all this money why am i getting
all this [ __ ]
i'm ready to do i really didn't do that
i don't know these people but you know
these [ __ ] strangers
you know but just you know then you get
that's a drug too i get addicted to that
[ __ ] strangers
you guys don't notice but you're in the
airport you're talking to the [ __ ]
uh one of the air clerks the next thing
you know you have in the office
it's just sick it's really sick with the
illness
but then but again there's a maturation
process that we all go through
and that's most significant to to to
know the evolution of of
what michael gerard tyson has been
through from the beginning
and and but but you i don't think he
would ever change the thing about the
journey
now you because it made you the man you
are today because as i get older
i realized why i wasn't there that way
and i never thought about that i had
mother
i had big-time mother issues and stuff
right but um and you addressed that also
in your one-man show which i saw i love
the intro and i love the the clips that
you do
and on the vegas show the one-man show
you know uh the
the truth what was the what's the
undisputed truth undisputed truth
correct
and then and it shows it just kind of
gives you a brief history
but again like i said i think that the
greatest part of the evolution is being
able to
kind of laugh at yourself and say hey
listen we have to laugh at yourself can
we take ourselves too seriously tough
guys and we can't
die and stuff and then i think for the
most part i think
all of us especially as athletes i'm a
former athlete like i wish
i wish that uh you know i had my little
letters for different schools you know
iowa state and like i think indiana
yeah bro and you know because i wanted
to play footballs i want to play
quarterback i want to play football and
then
obviously you know if a guy imagine
telling
imagine telling a single mother who
takes public transportation she's got
two or three jobs
for some reason i don't know how i had a
i went to a private school i had a
uniform
and i had a bmx bicycle you know how
important that was
and then and then and you know from
where we grew up you don't you don't
know about tomorrow you don't know about
tomorrow so
[ __ ] you know it's not promised so so
but the point was i was trying to figure
all of those things out
and and then you start to realize you
know my mother
again this is kind of where our synergy
synergy comes into book but with my
mother my particular mother it went from
she made me what's called a citizen of
the world meaning that
so i grew up with a group of kids that
you know two indian kids they were twins
nimish and darmish then i had the the
irish kid brendan feely
and then i had the tony was the italian
kid and then we so i i grew up in his
little rascals you know when we all rode
bikes together and
and it didn't matter we weren't looking
at color we weren't looking at religion
we weren't looking anything we just
we just hung out and we threw rocks and
we got into trouble and threw snowballs
through windows and ran and
you know do just what kids do yeah um
because because we were talking about
that earlier mike and i were talking
about how you know just
although all of this racism and this
unaccepting of of
others and so that's a taught behavior
yeah nobody's born a racist
yeah nobody's born you know bigot i
think that's that's a talk behavior
absolutely um yeah
wedding season returns at my bookie
winning season means doubling down
your first deposit winning season means
insane prop
epic bonuses and the craziest
cross-sports wages
at my book you want to see the means
watching live sports and betting live
sports
all season long rejoice the nfl has
returned
and that means action-packed sunday and
huge cash prizes
get in on the action and use promo code
tyson
and double your first deposit the new
players get up to a thousand dollars in
free play
designed to add more excitement to the
sport that you love
and the game that you love to bet on
that was the best in the nfl season
for your chance to win big okay use
promo code tyson and w your first
deposit your winning season begins today
only at my bookie that's a blessing
i feel like that's such a that was such
a blessing for me because i spent my
early childhood in park slope brooklyn i
was born in new york
very well and and that's where our first
uptown office was fourth and park slope
town record really yeah right on that
corner right that's dope man you're
crazy
yeah but maybe we have two degrees of
separation i know man
um you know so i i totally
feel like experience what was your
experience growing up in brooklyn
especially at that time too because it
wasn't very diverse in terms of
wow
there were like gang fights on our
street happening
uh but you know it was amazing man it
was such a
tight community in such an incredible
neighborhood
like i went to p.s 107 right around the
corner on
uh that was on 8th avenue and
14th street we lived on 12th street
and we'd walk there you know
from like second grade on i was walking
to school
you know the guy who ran the corner
store you know
everybody knew everyone everybody knew
everyone you know and i'd
i'd go spend afternoons at my buddy
pedro's house
his family was straight from brazil his
mother would cook us the most
incredible food you know and we'd just
hang out and
i mean i remember moving to l.a
you know it's much different because
people are driving all the time and in
cars so much
that the culture is so different you
know in brooklyn and new york you're on
your feet all the time
and it's a matter of the city people
absolutely california like la is
completely different
yeah like even on the radio side so i
was hosting mid days on
on hot 92. oh let there be light right
i was hosting uh mid days on on hot 92
this is before big boy took over or the
station they turned into a hip-hop form
they used to be old-school in r b
and um and i and i remember listening in
the programming meetings that
like even with kiss fm um you know where
ryan seacrest is
that particular station is programmed
for
13 year old mary seller from pacoima so
that's
so so just to understand that that it's
it's a different you know each market is
different than new york city obviously
yeah
it's about funk master flex and and and
chuck chill out and
and red alert and you know like you know
obviously when we grew up you know with
von harper and
yeah 107 points and frankie cruz
yep remember that kiss fm wbls ken west
kim spiderweb ken
spider webb yeah wow but also
the you know the [ __ ] realness of new
york city too you know we used to take
the subways
no time to hear no [ __ ] they don't want
to hear no books yeah but they don't got
no time that's the only thing about new
year's they don't got no [ __ ] time
there's no time for [ __ ] yeah get out my
way [ __ ] there's no time
yeah in no time it's walking out my
[ __ ] way in new york it's
very honest it's very hard yeah that's
yeah too hard
we just keep keeping 2019 yeah get the
[ __ ] out my way that's new york get the
[ __ ] out my way
yeah the energy there is is just
explosive it ain't like you know it's
like episodes say hi to
you say hi to someone you know me
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] what are you
[ __ ] gay
new york they [ __ ] explode you don't
know somebody don't know you say hi what
the [ __ ] you waving at me for
[ __ ]
it's totally different it's true totally
different than overly true
there's some crazy [ __ ] well i
had a pretty amazing
upbringing as it relates to um a place
we call money earned in mount vernon now
and i'll give you a little bit of a
description mike is very familiar
because mike was always at mount vernon
he'd come hanging out
um yeah listen my first wife robin
giving used to be his babysitter it's a
babysitter oh my god
wow that's right that's so crazy so we
lived in a place called the plazas like
i lived on third street you know i live
in a few different places on kingsbridge
road
but i do remember living in the plazas
and
you had there was like four buildings it
was the saratoga i think it was the
quincy it was the
you know whatever the name of all the
buildings were and i lived in we lived
on the second floor we lived on the
second floor and 2x so my mother and i
had a little studio apartment
and i think so robin um her mom miss
ruth
and her younger sister stephanie which
is my first girlfriend actually
so that's like you know third fourth
grade type stuff you know but that was
my first girlfriend you know
and my first kiss and all that stuff so
it was just funny that
he winds up marrying yeah my babysitter
[Laughter]
big shout out to robin love one lover
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] man it's so wild though so crazy
al what are you doing these days you're
just back from tour everything yeah
yeah you know what it's been it's been
truly amazing i i spend uh you know
most of the weekends on the road in fact
i just got off the road um
we did a whole mother's day run we did
ohio
um so it was myself jay holliday and
then uh joey beans from the rude boys we
did a you know very intimate
you know mother's day you know primal
statistics
no joe joey beans from the roo boys
written all over your face
um and and then the next day we were in
atlantic city
in the big stadium and we did it was
such a blessing to to
you know it was myself maze featuring
frankie beverly
so and it's weird because my brand for
some reason is
is an eclectic brand where for some
reason i'll be sure
the the catalog and the artist fits and
you can put me on the road with um
uh uh keith sweat you know guy
uh swv tony tony tony you know
you know bobby brown rbr you know like
and then then you can also put me on the
road with albie shore
lisa lisa and the cult jam stevie b um
you know and then then you could put me
on the road with albie shaw
big daddy kane uh houdini yeah you know
rocket you know so so it's weird like
it's just for some reason it fits in
with all you know because it's it's part
of the
the generation of that particular
generation where
it was still musical but it was straight
like i'm a hip-hop head
yeah like i listen to sting johnny
mathis and wu-tang
you know what i mean like such an
eclectic mix of music or
you know it's versatile yeah but but but
it's got to be rugged like yeah
absolutely like you know absolutely
it's the music we listed because we grew
up listening to hip-hop you know you
know what i grew up listening to like
but he said johnny mathis denise
williams winning fire and all those guys
and um classic yeah then [ __ ] hip-hop
just came out of nowhere like 79 or
something just blew everybody away
yeah and and and of course 78 right
you remember back then so mr mr magic
magic super super blast blast
[Music]
w-h-b-i or something like that there was
one station that played there was one
station that played
so and what we would do remember the
pause tapes so you get your box
and you've got you got your box ready
radio and your radio and you hit the
pause
and as soon as the dj starts poop and
you record and then you you you gather
all your hip you know your tastes
and then you ride around in the car and
you have all your hip-hop because radio
commercial freak that's music that's
dope
and and i think because we did that back
in the day i think that very
specifically
that's where the new formats of radio
like the serious xm's of the world and
things that is some of the stuff that's
commercial free
right if you think about it now we
probably created this bring your box
outside
just be standing around you dancing you
got your boxing people
the whole park is dancing off your music
that was the first
burned cds rip tapes
uh that's totally the [ __ ]
origin of that of streaming think about
it yeah absolutely
and and it would be perfect because you
would but you could do it on b2 if
you're really good at it
they would you know it's like it's
almost like it's the original version of
what the
what the kids call mixtapes now yes but
that was the original that's that's what
we listened to like
in fact we used to do that and my cousin
kyle west who's my musical partner
my older brother his brother his older
brother which i call it my brother as
well but it's my cousin
he was old enough and he had a license
so he used to take my aunt laura's
garage
so you should take my laura's uh wood
grain station wagon
and we would skip school and we would
drive downtown
but we would listen to that we would
listen to the radio we would listen to
the cassettes that we made
and you know yeah
crazy incredible time because you
couldn't record with it
but listen though it was so crazy you
would hear people from different let's
say i'm looking for i'm from new york
you're here guys from
manhattan they'll take grand master
flash melly melon those guys
you hear people from rochester new york
everybody you've been in a group home or
you've been
institution guys go back home and be in
their tapes and hear those guys rapping
everybody's doing all over the country
right and it was and it's funny because
it was like in
slightly different style because
obviously new york had its its own style
and just like
how atlanta and the dirty south or
whatever whatever the tournament
terminology might be you know and they
go in genres like every 10 years five
years you know
and it switches it in atlanta you know
that's how like hollywood was hollywood
was
was it it was los angeles it was you
know hollywood universal
now the new hollywood is atlanta um you
know all the things that the amazing
things that tyler perry
yeah and you know that they're doing you
know um georgia is huge for
production yep yeah and and now and now
at the end of the day
what people must realize is don't waste
your time building a huge building
with all type of effects guess what get
yourself a green screen you could be in
new zealand if you want to
i believe that yeah um um it's
entertaining the technology of
entertainment also changed now so
jamie foxx can play me in the movie
right he could play me now as
20 14 or 12 now because they have this
um
animation this gadget that may remember
benjamin button
and make him look younger yeah it's
crazy make him look like me so
we could do this because he said i
wanted her to do this movie before i'm
60.
he said but he could do me at 68 when
i'm 12.
yeah absolutely they can't have to look
for those young actors they don't have
to give no young actor or break us
chance in life we'll get this old [ __ ]
we make him 12.
and we know he can act too so he
big shout out to fox man what an amazing
let me tell you this
people what people of course they and i
don't want to say that they don't
realize but
this this particular entity slash
prodigy that we call jamie foxx can do
it all
yeah like i would love to see jamie foxx
and black tail
and ties just sitting at a piano at
carnegie hall
because he can do that and then he can
blame it on the alcohol he can do that
yeah he can do he can do it all but but
this this man is so blessed in terms
of his voicings and and his ability to
you know
his timing and his comedic time just
yeah his embodiment
he's a beautiful human being and yeah as
well
absolutely i mean i had an opportunity
to work with him uh on
the the first hbo special i'm one of the
executive producers of amazing dude
what's that about he's brilliant yeah
he's brilliant he's absolutely brilliant
the guys could have all this beautiful
talent yeah but working with him could
be like
a nightmare no
just absolutely brilliant and brilliant
talent and and yeah
you know he's still here for a reason um
but but that was one of my first
experiences to be
you know involved with tv production and
so on and so forth and i did more kind
of the watching and just kind of you
know learning
and and that's why so let me tell you a
story about jamie let's talk about this
we got to get him on the pot
he'd definitely do it but listen right
daddy jamie's awesome so one day my
friend and
friend needs some money for me this
isn't the agent for the asking for some
money
there's money no he wants to open up
this business like giving them money and
stuff
so this is my business too hope you know
but i can't never do i'm
fighting i can't take care of no
business in los angeles it was nothing
200 000 there was no money it was not
money back then
so um maybe i come to austin hangouts i
i i'm not gonna use to be in the office
i'm a street kid you know i'm champ
stuff
i start playing dice games in my office
you know since i paid the money
yeah we just start dicing so all the
blood everybody's up they were
hey mike this is the new um
employee and it's jamie foxx
listen he's selling um pages and phones
for us
wow yeah but i didn't know he was
a comedian because our friend also um
what was it he hustled his ass off he
did a hell of a job oh stephanie
yeah i am so proud of this man he was
there wait was he working with prince i
told joel remember prince edward joel
you know he passed away god wrestled so
much because he had the beeper shop on
on kawenga right next to the to the no
moves on leftiana los angeles yeah
wow wow you know that's crazy and it's
again it's
great to see the evolution of artists
and and hear the stories
like now the next the next move for me
is is
um now embarking which you know we've
been talking about embarking on
telling my life story now you know like
the new edition of bobby brown
you know in that format um because i've
been kind of the silent
one who's had so many different
experiences and and i think it's finally
and i and i would never talk about it
because i i was never about i never did
this to be a star i never did it for the
accolades i did it because
i was just in love with music and i
couldn't live without it and i couldn't
breathe without it and i would
you know and that's that that's
something that you know i wanted to make
sure people know
very specifically like uh you know
you know we did the first demos for
heavy d and the boys and that's me
singing all the backgrounds and so it's
because
i miss remember we were all together
that one night before he died
then we were in vegas we were the vague
we were all together
y'all were saying it was like um uptown
up there could anybody from town were
there
wow yeah amanda and i you know big shout
out to to
to mr dwight myers aka heavy duty the
king of mount vernon
let's not get it twisted i love king of
money here in mount vernon
four square miles and we and we come
from this really cool place
one of the awesome guy heavy and his mom
used to go to his house his mom used to
cook
for take care of us jamaican lady and
stuff
just just an amazing you know big shout
out to floyd as well too but just
floyd's still around me yeah absolutely
i think i think i love it but i think
portia i think porsche is just a
past past yeah just just a nice family
the mother of the father everybody
um and it was it was nice let's give a
quick story about have
the magic to heavy d is this
have was probably so significant
around the planet because for some
reason
what eddie f and and heavy and you know
we all kind of created
was a hip-hop artist
who was so gifted and talented regarding
his spit game and all the other stuff
but
you could play heavy d for your grandson
oh yeah you're your grandmother your
grandmother in the world
and the hardest cat and the hottest cats
in the hood
and they all loved it the same so so how
do you do how do you accomplish that
musically where
like i said i could play for my grandson
you could play for your grandmother and
the hardest cats in the hood
and it still rings like it still is he
wasn't cursing nothing he was respectful
special man yeah big shout out to pete
rock too man pete pete brock
another one again from mount vernon you
know i'm irish i
talked about this i was watching i was
watching pete rocks and those guys
the king of rock was running they did a
video with them and he'd ate they did it
the king of rocks
and nyc the five boroughs bro i don't
know if there's any more
potent collection of just superstar
human beings forget about whatever
success you want to talk about but
people who come into life understanding
what to do
or having a purpose i think you know
what because i think the hustle was so
so prominent isn't it judy's still alive
um no 2d passed away as well
and i and i just saw a photo of all of
us it's d.o
tooty myself hev just
what an amazing thing and i was saying
so so we're from a place called money
earning mount vernon
yeah um and and and it's it's truly
probably one of the most amazing places
to grow up
uh and just knowing the rich culture you
have every everybody from dick clark
yeah to art carney to even
crazy eb white you know the author of
charlotte yeah
you know obviously puff uh myself heavy
d
um um pete rock seals crazy ben gordon
um gus and ray williams uh uh
felicia rashad ahmad rashad you know
this like it's just
it's wild scooter mcrae rodney mcrae
yeah
um i mean the list goes i don't want to
leave anyone out but the list goes on
and it's
uh it's just it's just truly an amazing
place and to think about it's just four
square
no uh uh uh miss chabaz as well uh
malcolm x
yes it's just truly this amazing one of
the most amazing places on planet earth
and what's really funny is that
everywhere i travel all over the world
i run into somebody from mount vernon
wow always i could be
in a grocery store in iowa they said yo
you're from yo you know
you know my mother's from melbourne
that's crazy
that's amazing man how you kids doing
man everybody's fine everybody's
fantastic it's been it's been a very
different year
you know i was i never like same thing
negative since it's been a very
different year
um with the loss of obviously of of your
good friend and my ex you know
with kimberly and uh just what an
amazing lady and
and just an amazing soul and an amazing
uh human being and um
yeah so you know god rest us we came far
in life from where we came from
we came far yes sir we didn't do bad
yeah we did okay we did okay and and and
and i keep the young people as well as
yours you know and
and in prayer man and you know big shout
out to your nephews
little quincy what's the youngest baby
big shout out to devin laughs what
quincy is doing now the work i saw him
on the show star yeah yeah
working as an actor now yeah he's doing
you know film and television and
creating you know campaigns and and and
what's great about
all three of them you know big shout out
to little b show as well devon loud
quincy
and what's great about what they all do
is there's no nepotism
there's no you know my dad is just
myself no like
if i called right now he's in his room
studying a script he's not it's not
about oh yeah i'm gonna get this no he
he knows about the no you know they all
know like you know because not every
you know but every l is not a loss it's
a lesson
so so so a lot of times you know just
like just like with yourself
if you if you're in a fight well you
didn't really lose many
but if you if you went through a battle
and you didn't come out victorious
there's still some victory within that
list yes the lesson is getting beaten
yes it won't happen again right you know
i mean exactly learn the thoughts that
you made
and capitalize on them absolutely
absolutely but first of all i want to
say thank you
for um just probably being
one of the realest cats on the planet
ever to to have the journey that you've
had and
to you've always just been this humble
humble nature like people don't realize
people seem like tyson you know he can
knock everybody out and all this other
stuff and they see this
this guy and and around
like all we've ever done is laugh
together we've cried together
about life about situations we've
laughed together
it's been a true brotherhood like for so
so many years
um and and it was really nice to hear
some of the stories because you took me
back when we did unsung
on tv one well that was pretty good how
did that come out on top
yeah it came out i'll send you the link
to it it came out really well and i
believe
i do believe because i was told you know
by some of the
some of that my lbs that it's like the
number one viewed unsung
series and in fact you know i used to do
the voiceovers for season one so when
when the show first started
um you know it was uh i think the first
season was el debarge
after the barge family phyllis hyman
donnie hathaway
and the clark sisters so that was
an amazing experience as well doing
voiceovers and sinking to film and
things like that so that's awesome man
just been having fun with it man
just really having fun with it and and
like i said i look forward to being out
on the road i love
that's that's my that's my medicine yeah
what's the most important thing you had
things that you did in your life
um wow that's a great question
um those three amazing young men that i
i have as my sons um that's that's
probably the first
accomplishment and i didn't do
everything right and i didn't um
i didn't you know i did how do you know
you didn't do it right um
[Music]
the feeling inside oh that's so cute
yeah that's cool
i thought you were gonna be saying
because this is right and this is wrong
no no it's just no because because i'm
always thinking what what could i have
done better
how could every day i'm thinking how can
i how can i be a better father how can i
be a better you know
how can i be a better man how can i be a
better person
and in the light of and in light of uh
dealing with this industry which is the
devil as you know
and and dealing with all the derelicts
and the people that you encounter and
to try to set you up and tell me you
know what is that people you'd be so
surprised to be somebody that you rock
with that you grew up with somebody that
you would be best friends with
they will set you up in a heartbeat
because they're just not happy
listen hate happens within tenths of a
second you're cool as a boom
it's right there hey somebody come on
sin boom hate
hate is the first response you get
before love and that's unfortunate you
get a defensive
response then you get um um you know i
mean open response
you know it's just what human beings are
we're animals to that degree
you know we have more fear than truly
the animals in the jungle
have of each other you know yeah
we don't respect each other human beings
are the only animals that don't respect
each other
yeah we kill for fun for a joke hurt
people for a joke
well i have a fun joke that i'll share
with you something that mike did to me
we were at his house okay now i'm not
remember we're at mike's house and i
think was it the cleveland house
was that it might have been the jersey
house of cleveland i have no idea
so so michael and i have this affinity
to animals i love that you call him
michael
we we have this affinity to animals so
we love animals at one time i think i
got two mountain lions remember i named
them both lars and yeah you had the
tigers you had them yeah yeah oh no
so everything
kenny carso let's go okay whatever kane
corso yeah all i know is that these are
massive dogs but mike like is
one with the animals like he's just he's
just he loves it they love him
yeah so he's getting there to get up to
go train and do something
and i remember i'm in the back i'm like
okay you know it's halfway dark out
and mike comes up behind me grabs me and
picks me up
and throws me over the fence with the
dogs
i see you hike and see that and that's
other that's where you
it's like yo ike stop playing stop
playing all right stop
stop playing all right stop stop right
i'm like stop it
and you see so all of a sudden the dogs
so the dogs the dogs come running over
and they go to see
and mike says either plots or he says
something and they
and the dogs all froze i was like that's
some
yo scared the me i know i had to urinate
on my i did something but all i know is
that
when he threw me over the fence i'm like
don't stop playing mark stock come on
don't do that
and the dogs come running to me and he
said some german command or something
the dogs just stopped like this like
this next just breathing awkward his
breath i like his breath
like i'm like yo this guy through you
listen we used to hate listen we need to
hang out at my house in cleveland that's
because
a lot of times people will have concerts
you know you think children is far from
a lot of guys will have concerts in
cleveland so if you go to the continent
that's the concept we bring guys back to
our house we brought flames the ghetto
boys everybody
no that's because you had a disco in
your house yeah we did have this one
remember the year i came in remember i
think it was kimberly and i and
and i was i had gotten into the car
accident remember i was thrown from the
vehicle and i was in a wheelchair that
time
it was one of your birthday parties yeah
man it was crazy yeah
i was like my family like my personal
friend you know i've been through
everything together my prison time he
has been through everything that's
happening yeah
i used to go see you in prison yeah and
quincy was just a baby that's right
i brought quincy to the prison with me
and and that day remember that that one
of those particular days i think the day
that i bought the baby
to come see you was i met florence
henderson
from the british right she went to see
you
florence henderson was sitting in the
jail and i walk in and have the baby
have quincy with me
and i walk in and she looks at me she
goes hi like this and i'm like
hi florence florence took
it took the baby and it was sort of and
then little i think i think i brought
little al too come see
yeah yeah oh my god guys that's crazy
dude thank you so much man man thank you
i appreciate thank you you're
awesome it's beautiful dude
come anytime absolutely anything people
have a million people looking at okay
well you know
well this is what i this is what my part
two you know i turned 15. i've lost 100
pounds i'm on the health and wellness
thing
so i've started something new called i
am
new jack sexy now it's not what it
sounds like because it's all about
every morning that you're gifted enough
to wake up and breathe god's good every
morning look into your own mirror and
tell yourself
i am new jack sexy so what i did was i
started
an apparel and and you know merchandise
line with cool hats and got camouflage
assets new jack sexy so just go to i
am newjacksexy.com
and hell yeah get something for yourself
in addition to
give someone else someone maybe somebody
you're feeling that you want to rock
with or
let's say somebody that's going through
something harsh or it could be cancer it
could be something whatever
and it's just something to have
something around you to remind yourself
how amazing you are because sometimes
that's all it is
that's the best way to win moving
forward is telling yourself
you know hey i i'm good like we just
talked about it you yourself
human beings need that too absolutely
yeah i mean they need
affirmation oh yeah and that's what's
important and we have to evolve into
to having self-affirmation yes
cultivating it because imagine as
artists we're the most insecure people
in the world because what what do we do
our lives are lived by approval do i
like this album did he do good in this
fight
did you know did they like this
criticism
that he win the game you know so so it's
and and
people forget we even though we could be
superior on the athletic side or
or musically or you know as an athlete
we're still human beings yeah we're very
much human beings and then
human beings on a pedestal so it's easy
to shoot at us you know and and
now with the advent of social media you
know people so it is what it is but you
got to have thick skin wow
congratulations um on on all that you're
doing and with the podcast and with the
endeavors related to tyson ranch and
and the kind festival and these the big
concerts so
i'm with you let's roll we got another
20 or 30 in us let's go
let's do it let's do it [ __ ] yeah man
absolutely thanks brother thank you i
appreciate that mike amazing the fact
that you said that listen uh
that we have another 30 or 40 years and
think where did he think you're going
after that when it's over
no tango let me know
no idea no idea that's okay too yeah
it's beautiful
it's awesome hey everybody thanks for
watching
and listening to this awesome episode of
hot boxing
be sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel hot boxing with mike tyson
head to hotboxingpodcast.com for the
dope merch
new merch man it's fresh it's hot twink
responsibly
dope we got twink coming soon
cbd copper gel copper pain relief
cream we've got our tyson ranch flower
available in hybrid sativa and indica
strains
and guess what soon to come we will have
a new stream called
new jack sexy from the secret garden
[ __ ] one
love yes we will yes we will
plant our seeds in the secret garden
absolutely man
absolutely all right everybody mike
awesome episode man beautiful brother
i'm evan britton i'm mike tyson
we're i'll be sure
[Music]
you